[Music]
that you know 99% of the theories out
there are the beliefs of people out
there are that we humans our forefathers
cro-magnons from I know we had something
to do with the extension of an animal's
wiener killed them up competed them had
sex with them you know there's all these
theories that we had something to do
with it and so the first question comes
up is whether we did have something to
do with them right with their extinction
and we can make the assumption you know
mother nature takes out humans out of
the equation when and ourselves be
around and we do have a little evidence
to show that this would that you know
that we have middle to do with the
extinction of the Nano thoughts we have
man of Java Indonesia man you know he
lived around maybe 800,000 years ago in
the island of Java Indonesia we have man
of paquimé we don't have his head any
more his skull anymore but they made a
you know a little mock-up of it and and
he was also like maybe 700,000 800,000
years ago in China and these were Homo
erectus level specimens and you know
these two guys died they did not evolve
into a Heidelberg level type of home and
hominid Ori to an and earth or in to
human date their lineage just whittled
out and I what you did they date those
again they dated these to about 700,000
800,000 years ago so he's died and so
species do die they don't all evolved to
think that that they all evolved and to
think that we had something to do with
in Java man and pequin man you know the
the student they gather like this this
notion right and and then you've got the
other issue which I always bring up and
that's uh you know you have 5 min to
thought the last five nano those in a
cave and a stone falls and kills all
five of them does it last fighting anger
those does it make sense to say well you
know a rock caused the extinction of the
nano-cells
yeah technically it did but how did they
end up with five mana thoughts
so if humans came into Europe and
assuming you know either admixed with
them or kill them or out competed them
or whatever
if nanda those were already in decline
that's what we have to explain and not
the fact that we came in you know the we
were the final straw that broke the
camel's last Hannah felt died of a heart
attack you can see right thank you all
right that's the point and and there's a
little bit of that as well you know if
Neanderthals were already declined in a
lot of studies and a lot of the
paleontologists have this notion that's
gut feeling that they were already
declined that was a very sparse very low
dense population and that we came in
there until the night we finished them
off finally we finished them all that's
assumed yeah we killed them but then
they were already in decline they
already had sparse population they had
low density we have to explain that how
did they end up with that that's what we
have to explain but okay the number one
theory is admixture and make sure says
we interpret with them we had sex with
them and their genes got diluted in our
bigger population right but then the
question here is whether we could get to
read with them you know sounds like a
good question yeah I mean and and the
prior question to that is whether we
were of the same species or we were just
two races within a species for this we
need to define our terms property you
know bloodhound can have sex with a pool
Doberman with a German Shepherd because
they're all dogs they're all the same
species there are different races you
can have offspring what did I say we can
have sex to have sex with a dog
hopefully done with a chimp or with a
chicken you know but yeah the head
surgeon they had children in other words
they're viewable children you even have
a you know again Doberman with turban
shepherds and they could have kids make
it have fur top kids especially
specifically further and and so the
question is whether we could do the same
where we different races of the same
species or were we two different species
well this we have to define the term
species and race where would you
categorize likers and Thai guys because
they're not because they're sterile but
they are offspring of two different
races and and that's why I like to
define the term species as not only
interbreeding not only that they can
have children and they can have
successful offspring but they can do it
in the wild and that the hybrid that is
born from that mixture is also fertile
in other words you can propagate the the
race or yeah it would be a race in that
case so I'd like to distinguish that
race from species race is they can have
sex and have fertile offspring no
problem in the wild that's important to
what's the difference because in a zoo
you can put a tiger and a lion together
and they have blighters and tigers are
sterile but even assuming they were good
but you can do it in a controlled
environment in a lab you know but the
question would align get together with a
tiger out there in the wild because they
have cultural differences the light and
the line for example is a is a social
animal whereas the Tigers are lonely you
know you Europe's all by himself and the
reason I bring this up is here I have a
statement from Chris stringer he's he's
a prominent paleontologist and he says
this about the nanda those and this puts
this
in the proper light never those had
distinct behavior and they evolved under
different conditions from us so I still
think it's useful to keep them as
separate species even if we remember
that that doesn't necessarily preclude
interbreeding so I've got a problem with
that because he's saying even if they
could interbreed it even if they could
have sex they're two different species
but then we have a violation of the
definition well that's the point what is
you got a contradiction with the
definition we're gonna define species as
interbreeding
we cannot say well yeah you know the
they could interbreed but they were two
different species we can't say that
because we're contradicting our we have
to be able to use these terms
consistently on a scientific discussion
right and one of the main definitions or
the primary difference out there is one
that was put out by Ernst mark Meyer and
this was got here 1942 and he defines it
as such the word species he says species
are groups of actually or potentially
interbreeding natural populations which
are reproductively isolated from other
such groups in other words my defined it
is interbreeding and that's pretty
readable into breathable yeah then they
could breathe and have offspring and the
I think most people have that notion of
space and that's how I want to use the
word you know and so the question is you
know when the humans became a species
and were they the same species and then
hand results by this I mean could they
have sex in fertile offspring with an
adult and here you have a couple of
ideas where we got our notion of when
the human species started and you'll see
throughout the internet or wherever you
look that everybody more or less puts it
two hundred thousand years ago you heard
of mitochondrial Eve and she's two
hundred thousand years old now so
humanity started 200 thousand years yeah
and where did they get this
you know there's these studies out there
and that's what we got these ideas were
why 200000 years if you have one it says
estimate of the age of cabbage Omo Omo
hominids is 195 thousand plus or minus
five thousand years making them the
earliest well dated anatomically modern
human yet described and then you have
another one says it comes from the
behavioral sciences department in
California our species of humans first
began to evolve nearly two hundred
thousand years ago remember the word
species right a one hundred ninety five
thousand year old fossil phone Omo one
side in Ethiopia shows the beginnings of
the skull changes that we associate with
modern people in other words what
they're saying is about two hundred
thousand years ago there was this human
or archaic human or as close to human as
possible and he's two hundred thousand
years old and he's in this site called
Omo anyth you determine that from the
bone she yeah they look at this oh no
way of knowing if we could breed with it
no no I'm right but but this is I'm
gonna show you also another little bit
of evidence here but this is the first
evidence that you say look here we found
the skull that looks more or less human
what we would call human or it's getting
approaching human partly because of the
size of the cranial cavity you know
there's the this guy's approaching us
he's like fourteen hundred thousand four
hundred and fifty cubic centimeter we
have five fifteen hundred cavities yeah
is the hole inside your head you know
and so the cranial cavity of this guy
two hundred thousand years ago is very
close to human so we have to believe
that he had something to do with our
lineage we have another one adult to man
he's also from Ethiopia hundred sixty
thousand years ago and then recently
they figured out the man from hood from
Morocco
they say he's three hundred thousand
years ago and he said his brain is a
little smaller you know but the point is
all these approach the human cavity
this the size of the cavity right so
they think they were somehow our
ancestors and the best number they can
give is two hundred thousand years in
fact here you'll see you know that
if you look at Omaha B this he had six
hundred cubic centimeters when you get
down to Homo erectus
he's got anywhere from 900 to 1100 he
spanned a quite a long time then you get
to 1200 with Homo heidelbergensis
possibly also wrote a census in Africa
and then finally you get to the end with
all humans they have like 1500 so it's
like you know the the brain size is
expanding and that's more or less how
they determine these things right and
that's one way the other ways Janerio
but one way of determining that humans
are species right the human species of
modern man started starting 200,000
years ago they look at the brain size
they look at where they found it in the
rock layer does this hit more of us look
like ours you know and then that kind of
thing and then the other side they have
genetics and that also points to 200,000
years ago here we have an entry in the
for the word mitochondria in the
Encyclopedia Britannica
says research has shown that fragments
of the mitochondrial genome carried by
all humans alive today can be traced to
a single woman ancestor living an
estimated 150 to 200 thousand years
that's the mitochondrial Eve that means
we can all trace our lineage to her in a
sense right there that she was like the
mother of humanity right and then here
you have another one from 2011 Callaway
hope sapiens which emerge in Africa only
around 200,000 years ago so this is the
number that's being kicked around all
this has to do with genetics where did
they get that well they got it from a
seminal study 1987 10 mitochondrial DNA
stem from one woman who is postulated to
have lived about 200,000 years ago
probably in Africa they do a genetic
study right and they and they do these
regression analysis and they say well if
we have so many mutations every so often
when we take that back we end up 200,000
years ago that's where we think there
should have been our mother the mother
of humanity one one corpse yeah no no no
no no this has nothing to do with
getting to a woman if this has to do
with just a regression analysis I'm not
saying if we have so many mutations
every so often on the average if we take
that back we can come to the point where
the the first mitochondrial the
mitochondrial DNA that we have today
started about 200,000 years ago and so
we have on the one side the genetic
study that says 200,000 years ago on the
under findings on the actual skeletons
on the skulls we find also around
100,000 years we have you know several
skeletons out there and we gotta keep
that in perspective if we have a
thousand or you know ten thousand skulls
this would be an easy game you know we
just put them out there and say well let
now we can see exactly what happened
here but they have only five or six
skulls and from that they have to infer
or speculate you know what could have
happened so they have that all these
bits and pieces different regions
different skulls and you know they try
to figure out you know trying to figure
out the history of humans from these
five skulls it's like a puzzle and
you're having by piece and say woody is
this an outline is this a dragon what is
it and I have five easy and I'm not
trying to find out where the puzzle
pieces go but what is the problem with
all this if if humans if our species
interbreeding right if our species
started 200 thousand years ago that
means by definition of the word species
right if we're gonna use this word
consistently that means we can only
interbreed with someone 200 thousand
years ago but that's really mad at us
I would say we could not if if we didn't
use the word species correctly and
scientifically if our species started
200 thousand years ago
we cannot interbreed with Neanderthals
Heidelberg or with Homo erectus we we
find out
or actors today that got only only 900
cubic centimeters of cranial capacity
he's more like a monkey or like you know
he's a missing Lincoln like between
monkeys and us could we interbreed with
that guy
so to summarize you know we have to use
the word species correctly that's one
issue and if a specie if our species
started 200 thousand years ago then that
means we cannot interbreed with anyone
before that otherwise the person giving
the presentation has that you find the
word species for you what do you want
the opinion yeah
what do you mean by species you know
species is interbreeding could we
interbreed
[Music]
we'll go so what do you think of people
who think that they descent from the
Neanderthals let me tell you what I
think come on out
[Music]
you